little flaccid mine has more girth what
are we eating it's a whopper eat Oh
Ashley it's a whopper as a burrito
that's what I thought and I was hoping
it wasn't
I like burritos I like burgers I guess
there's a chance that the part could be
greater than the sum well the sound
could be greater than the parts what's
the same is it is it like a burger in my
burrito or is it a burrito in my burger
I feel like it's just gonna taste like a
burrito I hope it tastes just like a
burrito
everything is trying to become
everything these days instagrams trying
to be snapchat working trying to be
Chipotle apparently hope I don't get
e-coli this is the laziest roll burrito
I've ever seen it was it literally just
like a whopper you're gonna take it
apart oh it's just a smushed up whopper
it smells more like a burrito and a
burger at this point I know that you're
not supposed to eat a burrito like this
by the way I just need to get to the
middle of your idiot like corn on the
cob
I'm sure why not you're not supposed to
put a burger in a burrito either so get
oh how does it taste just like a whopper
nice taste tomatoes it tastes just like
the whopper with a tortilla around it
it's hamburger meat it's disorienting
how many calories is usually no oh I
know the nutrition facts though I do not
want to know what's in it and how many I
just said I don't want to know yo
straight out they're delicious and
everything you want there's a burger
inside a burrito just take my money I
mean yeah this is progression this is
mixing cultures listen to me if a burger
wants to identify as a burrito Who am I
to say that it can't people who want to
keep a burger inside a burger you're
holding this nation back okay can't hold
back progress we're doing it people
first there was steel then there were
railroads now la burrito get used to
this guys this is the norm
and it tastes not bad